what I want to do in this video is
introduce you to the idea of a
consumption function and it's a very
simple idea it's really just the notion
that income income in aggregate and
economy can drive consumption in
aggregate in an economy consumption in
an economy and just to make things
tangible I will construct a consumption
function for a hypothetical economy and
we can debate whether we can construct a
better one and you don't it doesn't have
to be all the numbers don't have to be
exactly what I'm about to do but this is
just to make things concrete in your
mind so maybe we have a hypothetical
economy where consumption is going to be
equal to well maybe there's some base
level of consumption even if there's no
aggregate income in our economy it's
hard to imagine but let's say there
isn't there will still be consumption
maybe people can do it by digging into
their savings so they're essentially
using resources that they've already
accumulated in some way and so let's say
that base level of consumption let's
call that 500 500 it could be billions
of dollars or gold coins or clam shells
or whatever the unit of measuring
economic activity is in our economy so
that's our base level of consumption and
then let's say if there is some
aggregate income if there is some
aggregate income people will spend 60%
of it and I'm just picking these numbers
somewhat arbitrarily so let's say if
there's some are above and beyond the
base level they're going to spend 0.6 of
any aggregate income they have and
actually to be a little bit more
particular I'll write not just income
I'll write disposable income and I want
to do that in a different color
they will that's not a different color
they will above and beyond the base
level spend 60% of their disposable
income disposable disposable income and
I make the distinction
just to clarify our model between income
and disposable income because all of the
aggregate income in economy does not end
up in consumers pockets in consumers
pockets and just for a simplification
you might say well yeah some of it ends
up in firms pockets but the firm's at
the end of the day are owned by
individuals so it can end up in
individuals or consumers pockets but
some of it goes off to the government it
goes off to the government so when you
think about income and if you spend any
time looking at your pay stub this will
become familiar to you you
have your income but you don't end up
with all of that in your checking
account or your pocket or your savings
account a good fraction of that is taken
out for taxes and so what you have left
over when you subtract taxes out of
income that is your disposable income
disposable disposable income and that's
why I write this year because that's
actually a more reasonable thing to say
people will spend 60% of their
disposable income they obviously can't
spend a fraction of stuff that they
don't have the stuff that's taken out
for taxes and just to visualize this we
can draw it this will be a line this
might ring a bell from your early
algebra days just the variables are
different instead of a instead of a Y we
have a C but that's still the dependent
variable it's a function of disposable
income and algebra you'll often call
this the independent variable sometimes
the most typical variable is X but it's
really the same idea over here so let me
draw this a little bit neater so we can
graph this what's essentially going to
be a line it doesn't have to be aligned
we just constructed a consumption
function that happens to be a line so
this is consumption right over here and
the vertical axis that could be in
billions of dollars or clamshells or
whatever else and then right over here
we have disposable income disposable
disposable income and so if there is
ZERO disposable income maybe I'll draw a
little table right over here if I have 0
disposals so this is I'll call it
disposable income and this is
consumption if there's a 0 disposable
income then this whole term right over
here is 0 and then you have 500 billion
dollars or whatever our units are of
base consumption and then that would
coordinate this this would correspond to
this point right over here in the vert
and the horizontal axis you don't move
at all because this 0 vertical axis is
500 so you have 500 and let's say
disposable income is let's say that it
is 1,000 whatever our units are so this
is 500 let's say this is 1 thousand
billion clamshells so this could be in
billions of clamshells Y I don't want to
keep having to say that over and over
again well what is our consumption going
to be in our units well our consumption
is going to be equal to 500 plus 0
point six times this a thousand which is
equal to five hundred plus six hundred
which is equal to eleven hundred so that
would correspond so this right over here
would correspond to so one thousand so
this might be a thousand this axis so
this would be eleven hundred to this
point right over here so that would be
the coordinate that would be the
coordinate 1011 1100 and this is a line
so two points make a line and so you
would have so in this particular case we
have a consumption function that looks
something like this
looks like that we pick two points to
draw it if you remember a little bit of
your slope you could view this as your
your y-intercept or in this case your C
intercept and that your slope would be
the point six and we'll talk more about
that in future videos when we dig into
the marginal propensity to consume a
little bit more but the one thing I just
want to highlight is it's a very simple
idea and it this does not have to be the
consumption function the consumption
functions that we tend to study in
introductory economics classes will look
like this it'll be a line that has some
intersection some base level of
consumption but one could argue it might
be very different
maybe the consumption function looks
like this maybe when maybe when income
is low for every incremental dollar of
income people are willing are probably
going to spend a lot and as they become
richer and richer and richer as their
income goes higher and higher they're
going to spend less and less a fraction
of the disposable income so essentially
what I'm describing here is a marginal
propensity to consume changes in our
first model we had a very basic marginal
propensity to consume it was constant
for every incremental dollar 0.6 of that
got spent so we had a marginal
propensity to consume that was constant
of 0.6 marginal propensity to consume
but you could argue that maybe a more
complex models of justified then one you
have we have a very high marginal
propensity to consume when people have
very little because they have a very low
standard of living they really want to
just get a little bit more just so they
can live a decent life but as they get
more and more income they say hey I
already gotten kind of starting to max
out my standard of living
I'll save more and more of it for a
rainy day